images that you've never seen before the
police response to the school shooting
in uvalde texas we have to tell you it's
devastating it shows a hallway
surveillance video first obtained by the
austin american statesman and the austin
tv station that would be kvue
it shows how officers stood by
they stood by and they failed to engage
the gunman as the teachers and the
children were critically injured just
right down the hall and despite multiple
calls for help now this video has been
edited so you will not hear the children
screaming we don't think that's good for
anybody to hear lydia luciano is in
vivaldi with more on this story
i don't know lily i just think how much
more do these parents have to take this
is just heartbreaking good morning to
you
good morning gail well these pam these
families were caught off guard by the
release of this video they were supposed
to watch it sunday but local media and
private released it sooner i'll tell you
these images are very difficult to watch
and to hear but some family members told
me it was important for them to watch it
in full so they knew exactly what police
did and also what they didn't
do 9-1-1 audio for may 24th reveals a
teacher's desperation inside rob
elementary school as the gunman fired at
the building from the parking lot
moments later at 11 33 a.m surveillance
footage shows him walking in and turning
down a hallway
one student peeking around a corner
spots the gunman
and runs away just as shots ring out
into classrooms 111 and 112.
more than two minutes later at least
three police officers race towards the
classroom retreating as the shooter
fires at them
by that point at least 11 police
officers were inside the school equipped
with body armor at least two rifles and
four pistols
police continue waiting in the hall for
almost 20 minutes and as dozens of
officers from seven different agencies
arrive they too
wait and wait
more than 20 minutes after that at 12 21
p.m the gunman fired four more shots
prompting several heavily armed officers
with ballistic shields to move down the
hallway but they still didn't try to
enter the classroom
nearly an hour into the massacre the
gunman hadn't been stopped and one
officer is seen sanitizing his hands
before returning to lean behind a wall
finally at 12 50 law enforcement
breaches the classroom killing the
gunman
an hour and 17 minutes after he entered
the school
the footage came out as several families
of the children killed were in
washington d.c advocating for gun reform
it's sudden release days before a
scheduled private hearing left some
feeling shocked betrayed devastated all
over again you broke us today for a
minute but we're not going back home
we're going to stay and we're going to
fight in uvalde mayor don mclaughlin
berated the media for sharing the leaked
video the way that video was released
today is one of the most chicken things
i've ever seen but some community
members said the criticism was misguided
[Music]
edda martinez's son escaped rob
elementary school during the shooting he
called the law enforcement response a
disgrace it's like ptsd you see them and
you just want to
go after them you know
anger rage they're just cowards
you need to resign
i remember those shots being fired
nicole ogburn taught fourth grade at rob
elementary and told us the gunman fired
into her classroom from the parking lot
there wasn't just one failure one person
failing us it was
multiple people
nobody's ever going to know how many of
those could have been saved
a recent report from the state's rapid
response training center said it's
possible that people could have been
saved if they received medical attention
sooner as for the video legislators will
still share the findings of their report
and the video privately with families on
sunday some families told me yesterday
when i spoke with them that they still
didn't know about that hearing that that
was happening others told me they will
not watch the video at all they don't
need to
tony
it's understandable lily thank you very
much uh nothing's gonna bring any of
these kids back these teachers back but
i hope that law enforcement watches that
video and that training
that lessons are learned about how long
one should hang back when as we
understand it the the screams of
children were scrubbed from the video
which means the officers in the hallway
were hearing them appearing and get
sitting there you have to wonder under
what world is it okay to do use a hand
sanitizer while children are screaming
and you know that they're in there with
a crazy gun shock betrayed devastating
yeah all of the above